he's Larry Fitzgerald who knows this
area quite well is dad still lives in
the area and the Cardinals wide receiver
joining us on behalf of visa uh we just
played some Prince music did you ever
meet Prince I did I got a chance to meet
Prince and it was a it was interesting
meeting he was not really a big football
guy
I shook his hand and told him I grew up
where I actually went to after-school
program in his at his old high school
played basketball in the same gym you
play basketball in and they would always
tell us when we were misbehaving hey
listen
Prince used to walk these halls there's
greatness in here and if you guys
continue to work hard to classroom and
abide by the rules and mean you might be
famous one day also and I told him that
story and he looked at men he said now
you know what it's like if a fan meets
you and and you know how nervous or a
little kid meets somebody and they're
like hi mr. Fitzgerald and I was at his
house though he would throw he would
throw he's at parties at his house out
in Paisley Park you know as his
recording studio also and it would be
like at 3 o'clock in the morning he
wouldn't come out in the state until to
perform until 5:00 and it was like an
intimate setting I thought he would like
you know I want to talk a little bit you
know it's came off our fifth Pro Bowl
I'm thinking I'm like somebody oh I'm
thinking I'm like coming to the house
man
yeah kinda purple sweater on and
everything did you have the PT like its
symbol did you know you didn't do that
nothing I didn't go that far but I have
my purple on just you know the song you
know I didn't I didn't wear any high
heels no stilettos anything like that
but you know I just decide my purple or
would you trade careers with Prince no
no I wouldn't I wouldn't that's that
isn't it so business is a tough life I'm
me traveling all around the world up at
all type of hours you know it's just
yeah but your prince yeah but but then
your your prince though oh you mean that
you can't go out and get a burger and
can't go to the mall no he's not if I
was gonna start off with the
entertainers he probably wouldn't be
like the first one I would who would be
who would be number one I mean being
Justin Timberlake is not bad it's not
bad it's good life yeah I mean it's good
at work and it's great at home you know
when people talk about Minneapolis in
Minnesota the Mall of America always
comes up okay so how important was the
mall of a meek describe the Mall of
America to people who have never been
here before so for visitors a minutes
it's a great attraction for locals when
I grew up didn't have any money in my
pocket that was the hangout spot you
could go out there and try to pick up on
girls you didn't get a chance to see and
you know at your own high school and
that was what we did until they put it
they implemented a rule you know right
when I was around my high school age
that you had to be you know older than
16 just to come in and loiter and ask
people we were - did you bring a
football and run past I mean the place
is so big no I would put on my best
clothes my new shoes and now go out
there and just post up in the food court
[Laughter]
[Music]
were you a pro bowler no no no I was I
was Allstate performer but I would I
everybody you know you get to a certain
age and then we want to know it's like
we're trying to force guys into
retirement like Brady Brady goes why is
everybody want me to retire you know
drew brees Eli Manning yourself like do
you like drew said if you'd asked me
three years ago I told you I have five
years yeah I feel the same way how many
years do you think you how many years do
you want to have left that's an
interesting question
I don't I don't I don't really know I
really don't know I mean I still enjoy
it it's fun I love being around my
teammates it sucks missing the playoffs
but how how are you gonna know you know
Carson told me that you just you just
know when it went is time and that's
that's what that's what he told me and
that's a lot of guys that told me that
as they got no dough you just you kind
of know the game with the game tells you
give it you got a hundred nine catches
this season but then you don't know you
don't know what it feels like on Monday
after that though it's what's it feeling
if you just if I picked it that's up and
do it on you and then took it off for
you and that's far what it feel like
yeah yeah don't do that
what about I enjoy coming on your show
you know what about Thursday night the
difference between Friday morning after
playing on Thursday night or Monday
morning after Sunday so I'll put it this
way I don't I don't even practice
anymore until Thursday I do a light day
on Thursday so I don't really start
feeling good until Friday usually so
playing on Thursday it's it's really
pushing it it's tough and especially
teams who have guys who are already
nicked up from the Sunday before puts
you at a tremendous disadvantage and if
you have to go on the road and travel on
Thursday you lose another day you know
so it's it's very difficult you need a
quarterback
are you available no not anymore okay no
I and I was going to I'm gonna go to
Cleveland yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna you
know what I'm gonna work a great number
even went oh and 16 last year and if
Dan's the quarter but somehow they find
a way to get worse
are you we had von Miller on and he was
openly recruiting Kirk Cousins have you
recruited anybody do you want to openly
recruit somebody here Kirk Cousins is
probably watching the program right now
if you'd like to say hello to him who do
you want Kurt I don't know I don't know
for sure if I'll be back next year but
Arizona is a great place I know you're
an avid golfer similar tonight to me but
it what a PCT times any place you want
there what if he says he'll go he just
needs to know if you're gonna be there
talk to me off camera true breezes are
freezing - you know yeah but I saw him
in the hallway I don't know what he told
you on TV but he said he's he's gonna
explore some options that's that's
that's really I was the word in the
hallway did anybody else see that no in
your mind you're saying that meanwhile
Drew's going man you're you're in
trouble you don't have a quarterback I'm
staying in New Orleans I got that
defense and those running backs they're
great Mike Thomas yeah
I don't need to do that but would you
how important is it to know who your
quarterback is gonna be if you're gonna
play next year well I mean that that's
that's everything to me I mean I'm i saw
predicated on who's throwing the ball
can't do my job at the level that i'm
that you want to do it if you don't you
know have somebody there that
consistently can get it to you so I've
had some years and Arizona word you know
things weren't always you know easy but
uh you know they've always done a good
job of you know address in that position
and they're trying - how did you get
over that loss in a Super Bowl - the
Steelers I don't think you ever really
get over it you know you learn to cope
with it it's tough you know especially
when you lose it like that you know you
know I remember watching Denver Broncos
lose to the Seahawks when you know the
game was out of hand very quickly they
were never in that game so I would
imagine doesn't hurt quite as bad as you
know having it taken from you you know
what a minute left you notice oh it that
was a well you scored the touchdown -
yeah see you're gonna be maybe the MVP
the Arizona's gonna win a Super Bowl and
then yeah Ben finds Antonio hands in the
minds of
you know what insult to injury was Kochi
Aryans was offensive coordinator on that
team and he wore that ring every wants
to know just one time but I would I
would say that would definitely hurt my
productivity though Larry is teaming up
with visa to upgrade local merchants
with new point-of-sale terminal so you
want to explain what you're doing with
visa this week yeah I mean what they're
doing is empowering local businesses you
know making it easy for their customers
to be able to be cashless in and pay you
know it's it's it's the first
non-contact sport I've played in a while
um you know you don't have to even touch
the you know the screen II just got to
hold it over the top and it's really
touch listen I've been using it
throughout the course of this weekend
I've been able to do some really cool
things curling with Aliza you know so
you know you might see me the next
Winter Olympics really possibly so you
could be like a Herschel Walker and
maybe you like the Bob's bobsled team or
something like that
nabob sledding is uh it's a little bit
more difficult not things in curling I
put on I put on a show yesterday I
couldn't look at that yeah my jeans are
a little tight I didn't have the
flexibility to know that I normally have
yeah
hey you're you look like quite the
athlete we have your draft profile okay
okay just coming out of college now I
will say we had a hard time trying to
find negative things in your drive
profile so everybody's read their draft
profiles here's Larry Fitzgerald reading
his draft profile coming out of
Pittsburgh
Larry Fisher doesn't always get great
separation from defensive backs plays
fast enough but lacks inner speed could
be stronger and more physical contained
by the University of Miami
sophomore year play two years in college
anything bother you on that no it's all
accurate it is yeah Miami can change you
yeah I mean Miami that year had a seven
guys drafted in the first round and okay
John Beeson and answer a roll and a
couple other guys were waiting in the
wings I mean this was an NFL team I mean
eight they had the same payroll there
too
yeah okay fair enough
those guys pay for the turnover chain
but you see the guys Pittsburgh couldn't
afford it you know they spend all their
money on you I had to pay to go to
university oh you did yeah I thought I
was on scholarship and asked me first
tuition how important is speed at your
position I think it's it's necessary you
need to have some resilience for speed
to build a separate but I mean you look
at the greatest players in history unite
his name a few you look at Jerry Rice
Jerry Rice Rhetta a four six forty you
know Chris Carter was a four or five guy
Marvin Harrison four or five guy you
know some of the greatest players
Michael Irvin the same way I mean none
of these guys were by today's standards
Blazers but they could get separation
they were competitive they were close in
close quarters tough in close quarters
and could catch the football in traffic
and not things there was a lot of things
that you need to do when you are you
plan to receive your position would you
rather be quick or fast quick yeah
because I can get separation but you're
probably running for 740 they said
you're kind of you like speed for seven
that's just what do you run right now I
least a four or five or five chains I'll
beat you in a footrace any day could you
beat me backwards I haven't seen you run
well I'm so I'm assuming so yes yeah
yeah I mean you've heard the stories
about my athleticism oh thank you I mean
whatever you want to put on the how
about we put watches on the line right
now what kind of watch do you have a
good one I think mine's better though I
don't know well you're not gonna lose it
right so then it doesn't matter how
about you did your wife buy that for you
what are you children I don't want it I
would hate like something that somebody
gave to you that you care about I just
bought this one here when'd you buy it I
bought it a couple months ago from my
friends up here at waxing how much do
you spend I don't I don't know if that's
appropriate what kind of watch I said
Patek okay oh okay all right
then yours a little bit more
I'm well-versed in that's like the Tom
Brady of watches right there yes or the
drew brees oh there we go
sand nice things about drew brees it's
always great to see you they have fun
this week and thank you for joining us I
appreciate you having me thank you very
much Pleasant for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]